on a pu voir plus de cent cinquante
mille tweets dont une grande vague de
soutien pour dénoncer l'agression du
polémiste marlène schiappa a dit les
injures publiques et les menaces
d'agressions sexuelles sont
injustifiables qu'elle vise une femme ou
un homme eric zemmour nos amis dans la
rue ou sur twitter
ce n'est pas une question de personnes
c'est une question de principe un
principe n'est pas variable
il ya eric ciotti à tout le monde la
litra même la litra voilà eric zemmour
est un adversaire nous combattons ses
idées mais nous voulons exprimer
aujourd'hui notre soutien total face à
la chasse à l'homme et aux crachats dont
il a été victime jamais la violence doit
l'emporter ou être justifiée jamais eric
naulleau vous qui êtes vraiment vous
êtes proche d'eric zemmour quand vous
avez vu ces images est ce que vous dites
il faut soutenir eric zemmour ou pas
parce qu'il ya plein de gens moi je vous
dis sur les réseaux sociaux là qui me
disent voilà moi je vous dis je ne le
soutient pas mais dans un même si voilà
je ne cautionne pas ce qu'a fait ce
garçon mais je ne soutiens pas eric
zemmour
mine de rien il ya aussi des gens qui
nous disent ils nous crachent dessus à
l'antenne ou à la télé tout le temps
c'était une occasion peut-être pour le
jeune homme de se défendre et de lui
répondre
voilà après je vois tout je vous dis
tout ce que je lis à voilà je trouve
peut être ce genre d'agression aussi
verbale cela ne sert à rien si on n'est
pas d'accord
eric naulleau moi je soutiens non
seulement eric zélande et je soutiens un
site très simple c'est que nul ne
devrait être victimes d'agressions
verbales ou physiques au motif qu'on ne
partage pas ses opinions ce n'est pas
une manière d'exprimer une opinion
ensuite je n'appellerai pas le jeune
homme je l'appellerai la racaille moi je
serai toujours
alors moi je n'aime pas ce mot j'aime
pas ce mot eric je te dis la vérité je
passe d'armé de moi j'aime j'aime pas ce
mot je te le dis ben brahim a dit le
meilleur ça veut dire ça ça veut dire
quoi une racaille eric ça veut dire quoi
ira de l'aeri inconscient ce monde
ouvert
guillot voilà donc pour moi je ne
regarde pas ce oui oui bien sûr mais je
trouve je trouve qu importe le nom
simplement je veux pas parler à la place
d'eric zemmour ils apprennent et même si
c'est son choix je peux redire juste que
en ce qui le concerne pour ce qui me
concerne
nous avons déjà été victimes
d'agressions plus violente que celle ci
et qui n'ont pas été filmé et dont il ya
pas de trace film est né un jour ou
l'autre il y aura l'agression de trop ce
ne seront pas des paroles ce ne seront
pas des crachats ce sera quelque chose
de beaucoup plus grave
et peut-être que ce jour-là on
regrettera de ne pas nommer les gens
pour ce qu'ils sont à savoir des voyous
déjà je regrette ce n'est pas tout son
appartement admissibles vous ne pouvez
pas être demain ce sera vous ceux qui
ricanent aux frais moins les malins
quand ce sera vous qui aurait découlé
quérin thierry calas eric qu eric ané
eric eric senet american mais qui
ricanent eric vous parlez de qui là moi
je parle de sur les réseaux sociaux soit
ceux qui ricanent aux dépens de zemmour
soit ce ça c'est encore une autre
catégorie intéressant qui préfère ne
rien dire parce que dans ces cas-là
courage fuyons il faut pas prendre parti
je regrette mais mes différents mais
désaccords idéologiques avec ces mots
n'ont pas diminué d'un centimètre après
cette agression
j'ai toujours des différends avec ces
mots je vous dis juste que avoir des
différends avec des mots ce n'est pas
une manière de les régler ou lui
crachant dessus en insultant sa personne
et celle de sa mère genre là si vous
admettez ça c'est la fin de la
démocratie